the doing of an entrepreneurial life is
not for the weak of heart and it's not
for somebody who's focused on the
byproduct of all the the riches and the
glamour you better love the doing you
better love your idea you better love
your people you better love fulfilling
that need and if that's excites you then
it's going to be a worthy life but if it
doesn't it's going to be
tough all right guys I've got Ron here
Ron in the tech world Innovation is all
about going to Mars or solving some kind
of cancer maybe even self-driving cars
and people would look at food and they'd
be like what do you mean Innovation you
though however have led tons of
innovation when it comes to the food
industry what are some of the things
that you would point at when someone
says prove to me that you're an
innovator what are some of the things
that you remember in your career that
you guys have done that really kind of
push the industry forward and help to
build these businesses well ultimately
this is a power powerfully difficult
business I mean you know people say to
me all the time you know it's what does
it take to to make a sandwich and pour a
cup of coffee it's just a to do 10
million times a week in in thousands of
distributed units in which there's
limited uh capital investment possible
and you've got to get people to choose
to do it because it's in their interest
to do it the the team members so this is
a a fasing business in which any number
of people have parachuted in from other
Industries and failed scale doesn't
really matter um Capital really doesn't
matter it's the ability to have a better
idea and a deeper understanding of that
consumer when I think about you and you
and I have had the pleasure of talking
before and kind of understanding a
number of the twists and turns of your
journey yes you were willing on multiple
occasions to blow up a good thing to
chase a great thing how did you know
when you only had a good thing but there
was the possibility for a great thing
there's a lot of entrepreneurs who they
just don't know when do I make a change
that can unlock that upgrade so Anthony
let's step back let's talk about what an
entrepreneur is it's often confused to
me an entrepreneur is a
opportunist in the very best sense of
the word it is an individual who can see
and sense opportunity generally an
opportunity to meet somebody's need a
need that they have that's not being met
as as well as it could be met if you did
something else and to me as an
opportunist not a capitalist because I
don't have Capital when I started as an
opportunist I could see opportunities
and feel those opportunities and frankly
I'm risk averse most really good
entrepreneurs are risk averse when I see
that opportunity I'm going to do
everything in my power to protect the
ability to get to that opportunity to
make that opportunity come alive and
that may lead me to do things that other
may consider risky but I actually think
it's the least risky because I'm
protecting that opportunity that I that
that I see out there so to come full
circle to the answer to your question
it's not when do you have
enough um
uh disruption enough
enough demand to change that you change
it's it's following where the
opportunity goes if you can see and feel
with empathy what's out there and what's
possible and what the real need is and
then figure out how do I get to people
and burn in their brains I'm the
solution to the problem then you have
real real opportunity and you follow it
one of the ways that you've done this is
you've always found something that's
unique right that you can kind of
dominate a category in and obviously uh
with Panera Cava we kind of go down the
line of all these different businesses
how do you measure and understand that
something not only people want but it is
unique right it's not like you're going
and creating another bir Burger Joint
that competes head-on with McDonald's
right next door you're specifically
going after these businesses that seem
to be niche in the beginning and get
very large how do you know hey I got
something that no one else
has well it's real simple and just hard
to do so let's again go backwards right
um you know I went to business school
and I I I can tell you you want value
creation value creation is a byproduct
what matters being a better competitive
alternative that's our mantra
that's what we talk about over and over
and over but but for your listeners I
want to simplify it what is being a
better competitive alternative mean what
are we really talking about here it's
having something that's so interesting
and and Powerful that your Target
customer is willing to walk past all
those competitors on the strip in a
restaurant and choose you for that
Solution that's when you know you got
something when they're choosing you for
something what is you know it's it's
it's like so many metaphors like dating
what what what is it when we were kids
what is it that that makes you who you
are who is your Target customer and how
why do they choose you and walk past all
those other folk what is it about you
that makes you different and distinctive
where's your
Authority and and ultimately it's about
going with that and having that guest
Choose
You in these businesses um I don't think
it surprises anyone that it's a people
business uh restaurant in general
typically have high turnover uh there
aren't tons of people who go to uh you
know huge Business Schools or have tons
and tons of uh degrees that are saying
Hey I want to go and I want to work at
an entry-level job inside one of these
restaurants but those people tend to be
the ones who are doing the work they're
also the ones that are interacting with
the uh customers they also tend to be
the ones that essentially the business's
success is built uh alongside because if
they execute correctly then the business
does well if they don't the business
suffers how do you find those people
people and make sure that uh maybe they
don't check boxes that would work for
somebody who's going to go work at
Facebook but they actually check the
boxes of what you need and they're the
right employee for a Panera a Cava or
somebody else well first I'm going to
disagree with you I actually think it's
a powerful opportunity um particularly
of of of economic advancement for for
people that are willing to join
affiliate make a difference um the
potential income level are often much
higher than they might be in Corporate
America you know I I went to Harvard
Business School and I'd sit in my my
class this is nearly 50 years ago now
I'd sit in my my classroom and think my
friends are all going to work for Exxon
or IBM and the guys that are that are
that are running the Gulf Station on the
corner in the middle of Harvard Square
those guys have more control over their
lives than most of my friends more
stability more more um opportunity to
actually make a difference so I I I
frankly believe the food industry one of
the most dynamic Industries in the world
with tremendous opportunity for those
that want to bring something to bear um
to to to Really move forward having said
that our job as leaders in this
industry and in in every industry um are
are are really to figure
out how to touch people so they choose
to see it
in their interest let me explain to you
what I mean I I basically have a belief
that in most
companies people give leadership 30 40
50% of what they're capable of and and
often that's why working for themselves
they do better the the question is as a
leader how do I get people to see it as
in their interest to actually do what
what what serves the organization
because it ultimately serves them you
know here's what I mean by that I've yet
to ever see an employee Anthony wake up
and say I'm so excited I made an another
penny a share for Cava today I made
another penny a share for Panera nobody
cares you know that's not what what what
what folks are about they want to know
does it how it how it affects them how
it affects their lives how it affects
their their sense of self many of the
people on front lines and restaurants
they want meaning they want to know that
they're part of something and they want
to know that they're part of something
that touches people and and often I
think that's our responsibility One More
Story and then we can go on but I often
think about Chick-fil-A and KFC and I
can remember decades ago but KFC used to
be worth significantly more than
Chick-fil-A today Chick-fil-A is worth
magnitudes of KFC what is one of the key
pieces to that the humanity the folks
that work there and that isn't simply
because it's commanded from on top from
the CEO's office that's been based on
the family processes the the the hiring
the way Chick-fil-A has built their
systems over the long term to bring in
people who are willing to to to put
their natural Humanity out there and to
be validated and supported um for that
there's a big difference between
different retail Concepts and you know
it when you walk in sometimes I walk in
and I think you know the choic is
between hunger and this place and I'm
going to choose hunger because the
people behind the counter are so you
know distressing and then you go into
some places where you feel you you you
they're real human beings and you're
touched that's what we're trying to
create but we can't make it we can
create the environment for it food is
something that uh is a very intimate
experience right you're literally
somebody is making something and you're
putting it into your body um you all
have done a great job of focusing on not
only the envir environment as you just
described but also what the product is
and kind of what people are actually
putting into their body how much of that
is all related under a single philosophy
versus you could see a business be
really good at the environment and
horrible at the product or vice versa
maybe they're great at the product and
horrible at the environment well I I I'd
make two comments to you first more
broadly food is
sensual I mean I have a sensual reaction
to it my senses get react to it I can
salivate at the thought of certain food
when I'm in the mood for it and we all
have that reaction so to me I want to
create lust in in a in a sort of Primal
kind of way um but Lust For That
salvation that occurs that's so good
that I so want it um I desire it's on my
brain at 11 o'clock in the morning I
want that thing in noon and we all know
that kind of experience that's what
we're trying to create with food now now
more broadly you speak to is it food is
it the environment and Anthony I'm going
to tell you something it's all of it
it's called a total experience you know
you know you buy your I see you with
your Apple airpods on right you know
it's it's not just the airpods the box
that comes in it it's the pack it's the
totality of the whole and so we're often
defined by our weakest element not our
strongest element and if anything is
offputting or out of balance to that
total experience you lose so I often
think of what I do is live performance
art I'm creating a show a script I'm
trying to engage in that script in
having a way in which you feel when
you're in relationship with our
experience and to do that one of the key
pieces of it is where's our Authority
come from we better have some Authority
not because we claim it in advertising
because we really own it but where is
our Authority and then what are we
authentically real about because there
not enough to say today I make pizza and
tomorrow I make chicken sandwiches what
am I really got staying power what am I
committed to and I think of that in
every relationship it's not different
we've talked about the environment kind
of inside the four walls of the actual
restaurant itself and the product but
there's a lot that goes into that
product and that environment that
happens outside of the restaurant and so
things like the supply chain things like
ingredients things like even inflation
and macroeconomics can all Impact your
ability to get the right things on time
at the right cost and kind of make one
of these Concepts work on a national or
International
scale how do you handle not having
control of some of those things outside
of the restaurant and I'll give you a
good example in the technology World
Tesla has said hey look you know what
we're going to do we're going to go
manufacture as many of these parts as we
can so we can vertically integrate our
manufacturing and our facilities so that
we can hold
control are there restaurants that do
that how do you think about what goes on
before the ingredients and the supplies
get to the restaurant and what have you
guys done over the years to kind of
optimize that to give yourselves kind of
the best shot at producing the end
result the end environment that you're
looking
for right okay so let's go higher level
and then we're going to go narrow to
your question so I I I touched on this
before we got to separate means ends and
byproducts that's how I think um the way
I tell it is through the story of A
friend of mine type one diabetic this
guy's goal in life is to stay alive as
long as you and me Anthony but that's a
a byproduct he can't make life for
himself any more than we can make
happiness what's it a byproduct of in
his case keeping his blood sugar between
80 and 180 when he does that he has
longevity when he doesn't do that he's
got medical problems that's the end that
drives the byproduct what are the means
in his case diet exercise insulin
control that drives to the end which
creates the byproduct
I think the restaurant business is the
same thing all right many people talk
about the value creation I had I ran a
public company for 20 27 years longer
than Cal Ripken played baseball and when
we talk about it you know um people
often talk about you know our last two
decades of public company we delivered
the strongest returns of any public
restaurant company twice Starbucks four
times Chipotle I'm told we beat Warren
Buffett's Brookshire halfway or
annualized returns were 25% but that is
all a byproduct of what what I'm trying
to say to your your listeners is it's a
byproduct of staying focused on what
really matters which is not the supply
chain in of itself for not the
macroeconomics but are we better at
something for some of our Target
customers and if we really are better at
that and they get it and they know it
and we're on their short list they're
going to walk past those other folks and
come to us that's where our energy needs
to be so I'm often asked on on
on by the media by of of all kinds you
know how am I reacting to wage inflation
how am I reacting to
macroeconomics how am I reacting to you
know the political environment and you
know what I say certainly it's what I
think is you know what none of us know
what's going to happen I'm not your pund
if I'm not the right guy to see if you
want to pundit on the economy what I'm
good at and what I know is that our team
whatever the conditions we Face they
will be faced by all of our competitors
we will figure out better ways to adjust
and adopt to that than our competitors
so I stay focused on being a better
competitive
alternative understanding that if any of
my inputs adjust or change we need to
adjust and change and figure out how to
get through through that same with Co
another piece that's very similar but in
the end it still comes down to being a
better competitive alternative so what
I'd say your listeners is separate
out what's an
input what's your end and you better
understand what you're end is because
that's the need you're meeting for your
guests that's what really matters to
them and then worry less about the the
the byproduct or value creation it will
happen if you really got a better
competitive alternative I mean to me
it's just a
there's this um thought process of like
you want Gamers right you want people
who want to go out and play the game for
playing the game they're competitive
they're they're true entrepreneurs
whether it's the business they're in or
it was another business they want to
compete and that sounds a lot like what
you were doing and describing where does
that come from for you wh why are you
like well first I gotta argue with you
buddy I'm not sure we want people that
are Gamers all the time right I mean we
want people that want to be part
of the army
because you know that we need that in
our army you were in the Army I believe
right I don't know what what what what
you're in but but you need people who
who want that in their lives right you
know everybody can't be the general and
we need people that that that want to
come to work make a difference touch the
lives of
their guests touch the lives of their of
their um employees their team members we
want all of that and so I think you know
um I I I I think I don't want Gamers I
don't you know here's what I don't want
when I hire people I don't want somebody
who's gon to give me 110% for 90 days I
want people can give me 95% of what
they're capable of for the next five
years because learning our businesses
understanding our businesses staying
present with it taking care of our
people taking care of our customers
that's stuff that we need consistent the
and stability for now I also want to
have people that bring a certain level
of energy to it I will tell you you know
um you asked me about me for me it was
always rooted in in this being the means
to making a difference in the world I
could have gone into politics I could
have gone into a lot of social justice
work I ended up going into business
because for me business is the last
vestage of um of of of or of of
organizations in our society where one
person can have dramatic impact to me
you know compensation is like tax policy
um you know in a government you know we
impact people and I love the role of
impacting and touching people I love
getting up and helping people make sense
of it all um I love when people learn I
get I've gotten from this book thousands
of letters from people who work for me
20 years ago 30 years ago and said you
know I learn more working for you um
than I ever did in my life in any other
place I worked and I I I I understood it
all over again even though you fired me
Ron I understood it all over again when
I read your book and I think that's the
part you know that that leadership needs
to bring we need to help people make
sense of it all and help make sense of
it so that they win and so that the
organization
wins when you think about that idea of
entrepreneur ship um are there certain
things in your personal life um kind of
through your journey whether it was at
work or or personally that you point
back to and you say that's how I became
a great entrepreneur that's when you
know I was excited about this and in the
book you talk about at one point uh
maybe you were more into some of the
ideas around you know socialism and
stuff versus now understanding and and
kind of uh fully um you know employing
incentives and and capitalism and these
things like how do you think just about
what made you you as an
entrepreneur this episode is brought to
you by cal.com what do I have in common
with Chad Hurley from YouTube Toby from
Shopify and Alexis from 776 and the
co-founder of Reddit we all use cal.com
instead of cly and we are all early
investors as well cal.com is leading the
charge of scheduling Platforms in the
open source sphere offering you the
chance to harness the efficiency
previously reserved for leite
corporations and Tech gurus if you like
to have your calendar organized and be
able to have an efficient exchange when
scheduling but you love all of the
benefits of open-source technology then
cal.com is for you they are transforming
sophisticated calendar management into
an accessible tool for all via a
user-friendly interface you can
customize it and you can make your
calendar work for you use code pomp for
$500 off when you set up your team with
cal.com today again go to cal.com
cal.com and use code pomp to get $500
off when you sign up cal.com an open-
Source tool that allows you to take back
control of your calendar be efficient
when scheduling and make sure that no
one can steal your
time at its core none of those I don't
think it's socialism vers capitalism
I've always sort
of been a capitalist but I want I want
systems that work for people right I I
guess what I would tell you is the most
important virtue of an
entrepreneur is empathy
explain that the ability to see and feel
what potential guests or clients or
customers need and want it's not being
it's not talking faster leading harder
being more driven it's actually that
ability to see that need if you buy my
hypothesis my view that what an
entrepreneur does is sees needs that
other people don't see and sees ways of
putting it together that other people
don't so it it actually makes a
difference for customers and then has
the ability to therefore figure out how
to amplify that and burn that into the
brains of of the potential people could
use that need if you buy my view then
you understand that the greatest skill
is the empathy to see and feel what it
is that is going on in the marketplace
you know to me I have a a mantra in the
book discover today what's going to
matter tomorrow how do you do that right
from empathy and from understanding what
the generalizations are from one
industry to another what's happened one
place may very well happen in the next
place why you know empathy to me is
actually feeling what's somebody really
want what do they need when we we were
you know we're often given credit as
being
at helping found or finding founding
fast casual which is today a hundred
billion doll segment of the restaurant
maybe more I heard a number this week
Bloomberg said it was 180 billion I
don't know but it's a lot it's a lot of
money right and and where did that come
from it came from the early mid90s two
years of running around listening to
customers and seeing people who who were
struck with a choice fast food or fine
dining and fast food by that point had
become you know basically self
self-service gasoline stations for the
human body and and and and it was also
clear that but people need needed speed
they needed to get in and out
and you can watch people walk into fast
food and hold their noses they didn't
want you know processed food they didn't
want to served by people who could care
less you know in paper caps they didn't
want to sit in tables bolted to the
floor for Micah they wanted something
more and it was the empathy to see and
feel that they that they what they that
that if you gave them real food
environments that engaged them people
gave us we could actually change
the currencies from a lot of food for
not a lot of money
to to What fast casual was rooted on a a
better experience a higher self-esteem
experience that actually um um elevated
me as opposed to diminish me as fast
food did and that was a powerful need
and Panera was actually built to be a
poster child for that it was built with
that Vision or Paradigm so what I'm keep
trying to say to you is to be an
entrepreneur is
about understanding the needs out there
finding the needs out there and the
requirement of that is
empathy so will danoff uh gave a quote
to describe the book and as you were
talking it reminded me he said Ron was
obsessed with Del letting his customers
and co-workers at Panera long before it
was fashionable to do so and then Brian
zazy who was the executive editor at
Yahoo finance said in a decade covering
Ron's career at Panera bre I found him
to be thinking 10 years in advance of
everyone else and usually proven right
now both of those quotes make you sound
amazing so I I know why you would use
them uh but they also to some degree
have a complexity to them which is if
you talk to your customers today and you
understand what they want how do you
also look 10 years in the future and so
how do you balance shortterm versus long
term and understand what do people want
today and then what are they going to
want 10 years from
now because we're because you're looking
for the deeper Trend I would say the
signal not the noise the the wheat not
the chaff let's talk about a very
specific example I think your listeners
will find that more helpful so let's
think about Cava Cava has been one of
the May it's been a powerfully
successful IPO trading well over its IPO
price um we took it public I think in
June um I'm their chairman and one of
their lead investors um I've been
invested in Cava I don't
know for a bunch of years came to them
with an idea in
2018 um to actually buy a company five
times larger than them but I why did I
do that what was I seeing I saw the
Mediterranean
category as a powerful powerful category
so now that's what's turned out to be
true it Cava could go on to be one of
the great industry defining uh Concepts
in the restaurant industry but why is
that because their C first their
category is so strong how did I know
that well it doesn't take too much to
note that Mediterranean is the number
one diet in
America right every time somebody goes
to a doctor their doctors tell them eat
Mediterranean you know it's good for
your heart you know all right you see
that then you start to see the way
people relate to the food the spices
they're they're they're both um
different and they are also um enticing
they're familiar and enticing and you
begin to say if it's safe but
challenging and you begin to make sense
of that all and it doesn't you know and
then you start to look at the momentum
and it doesn't require too much
knowledge five 10 years ago to say wow
this Mediterranean thing is real it's
happening at a cravable wellness level
diet it's happening at a level of flavor
and taste people are going to Tire of
Italian and Mexican where's the next
places coming from and you can see it
and feel it and then the question became
okay we got the number we got a great
category how do we go out and build an
industry dominant brand in that category
and that's a different set of
disciplines I've been doing it for 40
years my partners are part of it we know
how to build and support industry
dominant companies and so we went and
helped Cava become what it could be now
they had phenomenal food they had a
great system but we helped them learn
how to scale up and and and take it and
grow and we were really their Sherpa as
they climb Mount Everest and so that's
the way you do it you start with
understanding and feeling where are we
coming from where are we and therefore
where is the world going and again from
that context it didn't take too much to
understand that this was powerful look
for the need with
empathy when you did Panera you're the
founder and CEO when you did Cava you
were lead investor chairman and as you
described Sherpa what are the biggest
similarities and the biggest differences
of having a seat on the ride but maybe
not the exact same one well I'd say it
this way
first everything I'm doing with Cava and
I by the way I did it first with obon
Pam which I took public so this is my
you know and I've got a half a dozen
other businesses so it's not like like
kav is the only one we've got three or
four that are every bit as strong or
stronger coming down the pike something
called Life Alive which is imp positive
eating
um which
is vegetarian it's where people are
going doesn't take too much good sense
I'm telling you 3% of America is eating
vegetarian but 40% want to eat plant
forward tell me where that's going okay
and they don't want if I may say so uh
faux food they want real food who can
make that in a way that's really great
we've got something there we've got
another thing I told you about called
Tate which is um um again it's infused
with the spices of of
the Middle East it's it's Israeli it's
Lebanese it's Turkish it's got Authority
as a bakery the powerful Bakery um
that's really worth your nutritional
wallet we've got the same thing you know
it's got It's got authori as an artisan
coffee rooster Brewer it's amazing and
then we have chefs in every one of our
units it's got food from the Middle East
that you really want to eat and it's
really fascinating how it all works it's
a you know place for breakfast to gather
for lunch late in the afternoon even in
the evening we got a business like that
right and and and I got another one in
in immersive entertainment it's even
more interesting it's 40,000 square foot
of of of mental and physical challenges
each one one to three
minutes with a farm the table restaurant
in a in a Craft brewery in the middle of
it and it's just amazing to watch the
people pour in you know the people that
want to get away from their screens and
want to do something and have some
energy you know and we're you know it's
it's it's that's where I think the world
is going but I'd love to have you and
Pina up to to come visit this actually
it's really cool stuff I mean I'm not
kidding you but but but so I'm I'm sure
we we started with this thing but I I
would say to you for me oh I know where
it was so for
me I today I get great joy at a at of
spreading myself over multiple
businesses
um understanding and helping Define what
the categories they're going to win are
and then using what I've come to learn
over 40 years to help people fulfill
their wishes and dreams to build
dominant businesses and often to provide
the capital to do so because we tend to
be the guys that say invest the money if
you got something good let's grow it and
make sure we have the organization the
capabilities to do this thing right and
to understand what you need to do to get
there I would say to you when I was
doing it
when I ran obum when I ran Panera um you
know that was a different experience it
it absorbed every moment every ounce of
me and one of the things that I tried to
talk about in this book Anthony is the
truth of what it really takes to do this
you know I'm going to go off on a
tangent with you for a second but people
often when they talk about
entrepreneurship and I made these
speeches all the time and everybody
glamorizes it there was a time it was
you know you you know and you make money
and it seems like it's so wonderful let
me tell you something if if you don't
love that business in my case if I
didn't love spending time with my Bakers
more than going to the the University
Club or
wherever right I would you never make it
because the reality of an
entrepreneurial life Anthony is the
business owns you you don't own the
business and and one of the things I
really wanted to talk about in this book
unlike a lot of the books in this genre
is what it what the pain of it all was
how do you manage that how do you manage
when you're going through massive
transformation I went through four
transformations in this business and and
each one every seven or eight years were
huge and the truth is nothing's proven
till it's done when you're in the middle
of it you know when you when you've won
like I did it's really easy you know I I
19998 I had a public company obom pen Co
in and I had four divisions obom pen
obom pen International OB pen
manufacturing big manufacturing business
and Panera and for lots of different
reasons we can talk about I had a
learning that Panera had the potential
be nationally dominant and for every
thousand brands that talk about it one
of it one ever makes it and I was really
bumming and and I was away on Christmas
vacation and I was bumming because I was
looking at this thing paner I said it's
got the potential and we're going to
screw it up as a public company and this
friend of mine looked at me said Ron
what would you do if Panera owned pen
inter obom pen International obom pen
manufacturing I looked at my friend and
said if I had any
strength I would I would sell
everything all I monetize every other
business take that capital and put it
against Panera and and and quite
honestly take the best human capital and
go down there myself and make it happen
and that's what I did and that's the
that's the reality of what the
entrepreneurial life is really like it's
hard and these bets and when I was going
through that the point of my story was
when you're in the middle of
that you never know for sure it's going
to
work you know you believe in it um but
you never know if you have enough time
and enough resources and people say to
me all the time you know the stock is up
was up from from that time in
1999 if You' bought my stock um you
could have sold it
for um $100 for every dollar
you
know $10,000 for every $100 for 100 to
one return between 1999 when we sold the
company in
2017 people used to say to me all the
time Ron why didn't you tell me you know
why didn't you tell me to buy this stuck
I look and go yo I was telling
you nobody wanted to hear it you could
have bought it by the wheelbarrow my
point of this story is when you're in
the middle of it it's really really hard
when you're in the fog of War when
you're in the middle of the
battle it's not so sure how it's going
to go and as Vince Lombardi once put it
he never lost the game he just ran out
of time there's only so much time and so
this is really um the doing of an
entrepreneurial life is not for the weak
of heart and it's not for somebody who's
focused on the byproduct of all the the
riches and the glamour you better love
the doing you better love your idea you
better love your people you better love
fulfilling that need and if that's
excites you then it's going to be a
worthy life but if it doesn't it's going
to be tough and let me talk about one
other thing sorry if I'm running for a
second but everything is about
tradeoffs right
everything you know you know I can
remember having to get on a plane was my
they it was a snowstorm so the meeting
got transferred and that meant I had a
you know it was my son's
birthday that sucks
you know I mean there is no such thing
as balance they're just
choices and you got to make clear what
choices you're making and what you
really feel good
about and how you're going to manage
that in the end I came back that weekend
and tried to do something special for
him but I I I I for me and everybody
every one of your listeners has to make
their own choice I had really two
priorities in my
life my work and my
kids what did I didn't do I didn't
exercise for years I didn't I didn't I
didn't go hang out at the golf club I
didn't watch a lot of
TV that was the choices I made it worked
out beautifully in my life and I
couldn't be more pleased now got
divorced along the way that took a price
out of me you know but but
but I think going into it with your eyes
open is the right way
It prepares you um you had incredible
performance you built these amazing
businesses as you mentioned multiple
ones of them so it would shock people to
know that uh I believe on multiple
occasions activists investors showed up
and basically thought they knew better
than you did and they wanted you to do
all kinds of different stuff um for the
entrepreneurs that are here that aspire
to take their companies public and run
public companies and do all of that how
did you approach the activist investors
or what would you maybe have done
differently you know kind of knowing
everything you know now on hindsight
let's just talk about what I had two
actess investors attack me in 2008 and
then in
200 I think it was
14 and look at it's it's the nature of
our Capital markets our Capital markets
have become pervasively
shortterm um for lots of different
reasons I can remember when I first went
public the average company shareholders
held for four months by the time I sold
you know in in in in Panera the average
shareholder was down to I think four
weeks huge changes there's lots of
reasons for it we can go into it in a
different conversation but it's true and
what that allows for is for somebody to
buy the stock at any point doesn't take
very much to say whatever you're
investing in whatever you're
transforming cut it off cut it
off you know in fact take that
Capital put it into a stock buyback that
will drive up the stock take on some
more Financial Risk that will drive uh
and take that money and buy stock and
you know what we'll pop the stock I'll
sell and you can be left with the
carcass I don't need to worry about it
right because you know when everybody's
short term that's what
happens um that's what's happened in our
public markets unfortunately and you
better be prepared for that and
understand that you have the wherewithal
you have longterm shareholders with you
um because you'll live to regret it if
you don't and a in a public because you
know again when I went public you know
in the early 90s long-term capital was
thought to be in the public markets and
short-term capital in the private Market
to me it's the other way around you if
we invest with you we almost never sell
we're in it forever we're in for the
long term for building something of
quality um you're going to have to push
us out right you know you know most of
my shareholders even the best of them
are going to be in and out in a quarter
they're trading on the next inflection
point and that's what created the
opportunity for activists always because
the you know and and the great strength
we had and it's the reason I actually
sold it take it private was the great
strength I had is I voted I
disproportionately I was the largest
shareholder and I had a dual class of
stock and so I was able to have some
degree of control and then I had this
credibility of this success over decades
and decades the institutional investors
believed in me and stood with with me
every time but 80% of the time the
activists win everybody goes why not
we'll pop the stock everybody wants the
stock to go up but what you lose is the
is the quite a quite frankly The
Innovation that comes from
transformation and you know things of
value are not built overnight they take
investment they take commitment they
take energy and they take
time you wrote the book and you titled
it no what
matters when you think about what
matters in a business setting is there
one thing that you can point to and say
this is the thing that every business
across industry should care about you
mentioned the word empathy earlier is
that the answer or is there something no
no that's a means Anthony the answer to
it is building a better
alternative if you don't have a better
product or experience or podcast for
some Target customers you have no reason
to exist
and in fact if you're entrepreneurial
you're growing from nothing you got to
be that much better to break through
because it's really hard without scale
you really got to break out of it doing
what everybody else does isn't good
enough you got to be better and so if
there's one word I think is at the core
of what matters is being a better
competitive alternative and then because
as you get larger and larger scale
matters it's being able and things take
even more time it's being able to
predict today what's going to matter or
tomorrow by looking again that's where
empathy comes in that's where
generalization comes in to look out
three years and five and seven and know
what's going to
matter know what matters lessons from a
lifetime of Transformations Ron when you
look back at your career this book uh is
fantastic I highly suggest everyone go
and get it but the one thing I always
enjoy asking people who have seen
multiple things succeed uh go through
kind of the ups and downs of building
businesses is what is the most fun
moment moment you remember in your
career
probably we would do these what we'd
call annual family reunions I I got a
lot but I'm thinking about a couple two
right one we do these annual these
family reunions where we'd bring a whole
team together four or five thousand
people and usually we bought out the
grand old opera in in in Nashville which
is if you're a speaker it's an amazing
room to speak in because you're you're
everybody is right in front of you and
they're not deeper they go up and you
know and and I wanted to give my my team
something of
value and I I I and and I'd work on
these speeches and I will never forget
these moments usually I started with a
video something that connected my family
to the business my kids and I use them
usually as a metaphor in some way and I
just loved being on that stage with
thousands of people having them with me
get it I could watch their eyes as as as
I started to talk and I helped them
understand where we're coming from where
we are where we're going and to feel the
that love and that connection with them
and that that sense of Oneness and that
sense of Oneness with my family and and
that that all these parts of my life
were coming together in this moment that
really brought great joy that's one I'd
say
2 when you know we we converted this
business from what was used to be called
St Louis bre company to what became
Panera and we built a new prototype we'd
worked on this ideology and spent years
on it and then we we built one in in I
think it was statford Square Mall and
Illinois and the guys that were working
on it bunch of people Scott Davis Tony
Coleman
um Dwight juson I I they they didn't
want me to come and see it as they were
building it we met monthly but I
couldn't come and I'll never forget when
I walked in and I'd have this experience
when I ate food you know at different
times and I went my God it's like we
found God here this was like I walked in
and it was everything I ever dreamed
about as we talked about it and imagined
it and conceptualized it and this was it
we had done it and that was the store
that Panera built for 20 years you know
and and you could just feel it and
there's something like when you figure
it out I guess in a nutshell the
greatest joy of my career has been when
I have when I feel like we have figured
it out and the whole world hasn't yet
that's really what it is you got it you
can feel it that's an incredible feeling
I'm sure um I appreciate taking the time
to do this today uh you are a wealth of
knowledge um I must say also like a lot
of people will ask me whenever an
executive or an entrepreneur writes a
book uh hey is it a real book like
there's a lot of super real moments in
this book uh a lot of truths and I think
that you actually accomplish the goal of
explaining to people just how hard it is
and how difficult it is to do this stuff
um and and so I know it took you a while
to put it together and and with a lot of
effort so I appreciate you doing that
because I learned from it and I think a
lot of other people will learn from it
as well where can we send people to find
you on the internet um if if they like
this and want to figure out what El Ron
shake.com r n s
i.com you can order the book at any book
seller your Independence we would
recommend but any book seller has it and
you know um you can reach me at again
through the messaging app at Ron
shake.com and certainly my Google or
Gmail is available on the
internet Ron thank you so much we'll
definitely do it again in the future
thank you Anthony this is fun you ask
great questions